foreign
[Music]
this class is a very beginner's safety
class and it's ideal for the person
who's afraid to shoot and it gives them
a little bit of opportunity they spend
one to two hours in the classroom we
like to answer all their questions and
then we come to the range and give them
a sample of how to shoot
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
and I am the firearm instructor today
and also on the board of Washington
State Rifle and Pistol as the government
Affairs person women are the fastest
growing group of gun owners in America a
lot of that has to do with the increase
in crime especially in our area in
Washington state where the crime rates
are real highs especially here in the
Puget Sound so safe Direction and not
putting your finger on the trigger you
won't have this gun going off by itself
I give up my time to help women so that
they can safely protect themselves I
survived a home invasion by two men they
didn't know I was home they came in my
house and I shouted out a command to
them and they were in my kitchen and
they pulled open the sliding glass door
one guy took off and the other froze on
my back porch so when he froze on my
back porch I stayed away from him enough
to see if it was going to be a threat or
not and so I did not have to personally
pull out my firearm it was there ready
to go if I saw he was going to come
toward me or I saw that it was going to
be a threat but in this situation I was
very fortunate by the grace of God he
froze and he took all my commands so I
told him to stay there don't move why
were you in my house and then I had the
neighbor call the cops from that people
kept asking me can you please show me
how to shoot so I can protect myself
this is the good that came out of that
it helps women because we are easy
targets but at least a firearm levels
the fight between us and our attackers
[Music]
using a gun quite honestly they make me
nervous
you always hear about the accidents of
course little kids getting shot
it can be very very intimidating and so
I want to be more comfortable handling
them
I'm now married to a law enforcement
officer and we have gone shooting I
believe once in the 11 years we've been
married he's trained he does this every
day so
I love that he carries and I never worry
about it but when he is gone that is
when then I become concerned for my
safety and I don't have that that
comfort and reassurance of someone that
knows how to actively handle a gun and
protect me from an intruder or someone
who wants to harm us the criminals are
starting to think oh women are more of a
Sitting Duck and we're saying no
absolutely not we're going to take
matters into our own hands and protect
ourselves the same way men have been
doing for years
one night my son and I came home from an
event and he ran into the house and I
was on the phone
um you know how the when the phone's on
your car system so I wanted to finish
the phone call before going in the house
and did that
and there was a gentleman a couple of
guys in our neighborhood this is in
University Place very quiet neighborhood
that we're driving around and attempting
to break into
cars so the car pulled up behind me
which t-bowed me T-boned me into my
driveway the car was running and one of
the guys got out and attempted the car
next to me first which was locked and
then attempted my passenger door which
was unlocked and opened it and I was in
the driver's seat and were just like
looking at each other you know and he
had an excuse that he was he thought it
was his girlfriend's car and her house
and I said well she doesn't live here
and and then he got into the car and
drove off
Two Men and myself how could I protect
myself
it would be difficult women and not as
strong we need something a little
stronger to help protect us
[Music]
women are taking you know want to take
command of their situation they still
want to live their life but they want to
be able to protect themselves and so the
being that they are the fastest growing
group you'll see they are the the ones
getting the most concealed permits right
now and again they are the ones who are
also the most popular rifle for them is
the modern sporting rifle which is
sometimes referred to as an AR-15 or
ArmaLite rifle
so I always ask in a class what is AR-15
stand for and they the the most common
things are automatic rifle or assault
rifle and none of those are accurate
the pink one
the pink one is the exact same gun as
that one
today I demonstrated shooting a bolt
action 30-06 hunting rifle which has
much more recoil or shotguns which are
sometimes people say oh have that for
home defense a lot of recoil they don't
it doesn't work for all women the modern
sporting rifle can adjust to fit our
smaller frames there's little recoil
compared to the other rifles and so it
makes it safer for a woman both in a
home defense situation or if they're
shooting on rifle League or something
like that
this bill prohibits the sale import
distribution or manufacture of any
military style assault a weapon in the
state of Washington starting today I'm
happy to say that
the band will also ban 22 caliber rifles
which are your fun planking rifles and
going to the range and target shooting
the cartridges are real tiny there's no
recoil
okay
does this look like a military rifle to
you no and they're just a safe
practicing firearm and that one's going
to be banned along with the modern
sporting rifle a little bit bigger
cartridge but your hunting rifle the
30-06
bigger cartridge is not going to be
banned and that's the one where the
bullet would go straight through your
wall if you used it for home defense but
as you saw the recoil is very strong and
so it's not safe for a lot of women
they're targeting the wrong person
they're targeting us the law-abiding
firearm owners instead of the criminals
because criminals will get their
firearms they don't care about the laws
there's already over 88 pages of laws in
Washington state and 237 on the federal
level and and criminals will buy their
rifles through black market drug deals
straw purchase whatever illegal means
and so the law won't impact them but for
a lot of women it's taken away the
personal protection option of choice
that works best for them and you know it
so the law is clearly discriminating
against women AR-15 it has been the
weapon of choice assault weapons start
to look at these assault rifles these
are killing
we should just go back to having an
assault weapons ban an assault style
weapon of military style weapons AR-15s
aren't for defending homes they're going
out for Mass Slaughters supposed to be
in the jungles of Vietnam now they're in
for in first grade schools everything in
the news and media is making it sound
like this is the most murderous weapon
out there and this is what everyone's
getting to kill our kids in school
systems and uh you know it's so
dangerous but no I mean it's completely
misconception and they're not educating
us correctly it's a lie quite honestly
the misconception that the public and
the news is leading the public to
believe about firearms
these are not big scary automatic
guns that are being banned in our state
uh the AR-15 is a semi-automatic you you
could only send one bullet through at a
time and the public thinks otherwise it
seems like
the Constitution is there to protect us
and quite honestly they're just
continuing to disarm us and that it's
not intended to be a pun they really are
they want to take control they're not
educating the public accurately on what
they are doing and slowly they are
taking away our rights
wanna do it again
thank you